just some breaking news to bring you now
and Royal Mail workers have voted
overwhelmingly to continue with
industrial action in the dispute over
paid jobs and conditions that news just
in from the communication Workers Union
thousands of workers they say have voted
in favor of further strikes that's Royal
Mail workers continuing their industrial
action and walkouts over this
long-running dispute more than 95
percent of those who participated in the
ballot in the ballot voted for strikes
according to the CWU which represents
more than 110
000 postal workers and 95 of them have
voted in favor of more industrial action